hello everyone and welcome back to the
season 17 TCC Superfinal
again we watch s0 versus starfish and
it's it's really an interesting game
featuring again a very interesting
opening every opening is interesting in
the match ins they are free predefined
and some of you has been asking why
don't they just let them battle it out
without pretty finding any openings well
it's much more interesting this way I
don't know if it would be fair that to
the standard engines I think neural
networks would be would have an
advantage here as standard engines are
are kind of better when it comes to
really tactical position so here we we
as viewers get much more interesting
games to enjoy and they don't care they
play pretty much I mean they will play
whatever you tell them to play so it
does kind of make sense and we get to
see how our favorite openings are played
on the highest level for example if you
if you're a fan of the Evans gambit then
there will be an Evans gambit game where
both legal and stalkers will have the
white pieces so it's interesting but I
would also enjoy a match where they
would just go 100 games head to head
without predefined openings but maybe
they installed that at some point maybe
in some other seasons who knows we'll
see but getting back to the game Oliva
opens with C for the English opening and
here we have Knight to c6 in the d4 and
this is it for the for what they have to
play up from this point on it is every
engine for themselves and here stockfish
replies with E 5 when with the colors to
reversed
really love played east 6 here instead
of a starfish c5 but ok
a 5 by stock fish with b5 grabbing more
space in the center Bishop to b4 with
check nice to be 2 and now Knight C back
to e7 and getting the right arm auto out
of harm's way and Queen to a 4 now
attacking the bishop here and that there
is one game with that humans played
whereas e5 was played but here we have a
5 and already as of a move 5 we have a
completely new game so a3 are
challenging the bishop asking do you
want to go back or do you want to
capture and well Bishop to d6 is a
possibility
just best of Kafiristan d to buy we buy
stock fish with the shop character
Sunday to end now 92 f6 continuing
development we have Knight to f3 and the
now II for kicking back the night or in
this case forward with Knight to d4 and
now Scottish castles with III preparing
to develop the LightSquared Bishop with
d6 a black does the same and now brush
up the c3 shifting the bishop over to
this very nice diagonal we have Knight
to g6 now from g6 the knight can nicely
come to e5 if needed with Queen back the
c2 the queen is no longer needed on a4
and now Queen to e7 just continuing
development we have a queenside castle
by Lila so we have castles on opposite
sides definitely gonna be a race Bishop
to d7 and now comes at night to b5 and
here already a very interesting moment
do capture on b5 or not probably you do
want to capture because it opens up the
C file well it kind of kind of does but
it's not as simple for example if
captures captures now of course at some
point you wanna bust open with c6 but
it's not it's not easy to do that for
example if rook f2 CA what can just
continue developing there should be two
and now c6 can always be met with Bishop
captures and f6 Queen captures and
Bishop to g4 now forcing the rogue back
because if rook comes here to keep the
rook on the C file just b6 and it's a
now a better position for white after
rook e7 you can capture here and it's
actually white who is pushing on the
Queen side even though white castles on
the Queen side so very very instructive
idea this Knights the b5 move which you
can also sometimes use in your own games
not specifically Knight to b5 but just
because your opponent can open up some
lines in front of your King doesn't mean
that it's always good and such is the
case here so stockfish decides to go for
Knight to e5 instead offering the c7
pawn here but again this time you don't
capture it if you capture it then again
after the knight is under attack you go
back now you just immediately win back
the pawn so it's not really an issue and
already black has a
nicely open see file so after Knight to
e5 we have King to be one are getting
the King out of the C file and also out
of the check if Knight to b3 ever lands
with rook F to c8 now defending and may
be preparing to push c6 and h3 by Leela
h6 by stock fish again creating some
breathing room for the king and now rook
the g1 Oliva is now ready to start
pushing on the King side we have c5 stop
fish asking do you want to keep the keep
the position closed or do you want to
open up with D captures on c6 on Poisson
and layla prefers to keep it closed with
a four here stock which grabs the night
with Bishop captures a captures and now
while you couldn't go b6 to keep
everything closed and maybe at some
point maybe you can double up on the a
file and start pushing here
Lilla would be much faster on the Queen
side and so stock fish decides to make
the attack happen just a little bit
faster and pushes a for now it's it's a
good idea you want to push a3 bust open
the position however if you don't manage
to do so da for pawn could be a
liability sometimes in the future so Leo
just continues with the plan Bishop to
e2 and here comes Knight to d3 with a
check it's really a weird idea probably
a3 is what everyone was expecting and
knights the d3 comes up with the idea
that stock fish wants to give back well
give up a pawn sacrifice on material to
start the attack even sooner but it to
me it's not at all clear how to me it's
a it to me it looks like a move way back
when I first started playing chess I
would play a move like this with the
knight and my opponent would just
capture it and grab a pawn and I would
be like yeah that was good and here I
don't really see the compensation from
black but okay stock fish does show some
compensation stock fish goes rook to e8
a3 right away doesn't yield all that
much for black because after characters
and captures white has the very
unpleasant Bishop captures here which
now opens up
attack so you cannot bust open the
position right away you would end up
being down a look so here look the head
by stockfish and now push back that you
won and this spending nights the e4 so
the bishop nicely controls the night
from from e1 we have night back to d7
probably going for a five and now route
back to a3 not allowing black to push
the point at the a3 and tweening for now
stop which offers a queen trade which
Lily accepts and accepted gladly Queen
captures we have rook captures attacking
the c4 pawn and now it's not not clear
how white will defend the c4 pawn but
Leela finds a very creative way and
plays f3 and now you can even pause the
video and try to figure out is it okay
to grab the c4 pawn or not well I well I
give you a couple of seconds and have a
nice tip of my water so for those of you
who were able to do it I'm just kidding
I know all of you were able to do it
it's not okay to capture the pawn so
congratulations everyone
if you captured upon B three wins the
game for white since the rock is
strapped all of the squares here are
covered so the rook does not have
anywhere to go
the only square you have is to go of
course if you capture then you lose the
rook on a date and if you go here to
give up the exchange still not much
better just rock out for us on a four
you have the exchange completely winning
so probably something stockfish failed
to take into account maybe when
sacrificing that pawn for the attack but
who knows route back to eh and now Lila
just continues King to see to being up
upon and like I mentioned if you don't
put this pawn all the way to a3 it's
gonna be a liability and if Lila grabs
another pawn then well being down two
points it will be a big challenge for
starfish to not lose this King f8 we
have King to d3 centralizing York ink 95
checked King back to c3 in the knight
back to d7
we have Bishop to d2 guarding the e3
pawn and now h5 Lila stops the g5 by
pushing Age 4 we have nice to b6 now the
night will put
the c-4 pond also keep an eye on the a
for pond so maybe you can activate this
rook King to d3 and now King to e7 the
activate the King you have to shift it
over but now e for grabbing more space
in the center also now the bishop has
access to the King side as well
f6 by black not allowing this and now
rook to e1 and here Leela will now try
to shift the rooks over to the e-file
and double up there we have King D 7 and
now F for grabbing more space here not
allowing any Knight shifting to the
center of the board in the future King
c7 and now Bishop the c3 keeping an eye
on the e5 square preparing a 5 at some
point King back to D 7 stuff is just
waits to see what will happen and now
rook the a1 not not worried about rook
to a3 since it's still defended twice so
rook the e7 black now has the double up
on the e-file rook to e3 Leo does the
same rook e8 e8 and rook a to e1
so again he 5 being the idea we have
Knight to c8 and now comes g3 just
improving the position as much as
possible before you decide on any rash
decisions like like pushing a pawn so
Knight back to b6 and here stop Leela
finds the D the again very creative
Bishop to a5 just attacking the knight
here forcing it back and also the knight
is one of the defenders of the a4 pawn
so you have to move it back and King the
c7 if you try something like this this
losses on the spot and now you allow
five and now after some traits or or all
of the trades doesn't really matter
captures captures and captures this e 6
will be deadly since it deflects the
King from the defense of the night here
and it's just winning so after Bishop to
a5 we have Knight to c8 by stockfish and
now Bishop the c3 not going for rook to
a-1 to go after the pawn right away
because then you allow f5 so the two
rooks are needed here Bishop back to c3
Allah repeats once here probably
checking if stalkerish will repeat
knight the mises then probably what
would repeat and find a different plan
but stockers just says king to c7 now
probably Bishop a5 check will be met
with
came back to d7 but okay rook to eat you
now and here we have rook to f7 a
starfish waits to see what what's
happening and now rooked a one that that
the rook moves from the e-file if you
don't move the rooks from the e-file if
you repeat something like King to b7
then Lilla would just have to find some
other way it's hard hard to figure out
what way but at some point probably you
would have to wiggle your way out of
this f5 being a threat and then just
shift your rock over and picking up the
a for point but stuffy's does it right
away so Leela immediately goes for the a
for pawn rook to a-1 and now problem is
you cannot defend it if you go Knight b6
then still wish of the a5 and now if
looked the a8 going after the bishop now
you can still just grab the pawn rook
captures as the knight is pinned and
there's no way to figure this out so
kink the b8 instead and now Leah I just
grabs the pawn rook captures an a4 and
now Leela is up two points with a very
clear idea before it's coming and you
are busting open here on the Queen side
we have B 6 and B 4 right away
C character son before we have rook a
person before not bishop character still
the bishop that needs to keep an eye on
the e5 pawn if I swear obviously rook
captures on before and now King to b7
we've looked back the b1 and Knight to
e7 now and now this is a merely a
question of how Leela will win this but
like the title suggests it's a very
funny end game so rook to a 1 we have g6
by stockfish and out bishop the d4 with
ideas of Luke a 6 grabbing the pawn here
so 90 the CA to the knight will nicely
defend the b6 pawn and now rook to e3
we have rook to g8 preparing to pull g5
now comes a bishop to c3 we have King to
c7
and E 5 now finally busting open here F
captures with F captures and King beast
7 now now the knight can move so I don't
have to worry about rook to e7 and here
eek actress and d 6e 6 it seems like a
more natural move but I guess
you know it's a matter of taste both the
Moo's are you know quite quite good so
lil instead goes eek after sandy 6 we
have night captures and now Bishop to b4
preparing 3rd to grab that night so
night back to c8 and now rook 81 and
here you can see allele eyes completely
dominating everything all of the squares
here taken the night cannot enter the
game the roofs with complete control of
the e-file not much to do here for stop
so g5 you have to play something H
captures rook captures and now rook the
h1 putting pressure on this pawn here we
have king c7 and now Russia back to c3
rook F to f5 now defending the pawn once
again and now rook the h4 with Knight to
d6 finally the knight enters the game
but now rook F for you force a rook
trade here came to d7 and now Bishop to
b4 again you want to trade up a trade
off as much material as possible so
Knight b7 of course dogfish prevents it
but now rook captures rook captures and
now look the e6 cutting the King off
from entering entering the game and here
we have night to d8 going after the rook
if you try and defend the pawn with
something like King here just rope
checks the next move you're gonna pick
up the pawn so it's impossible to save
it so Knights the d8 but now rook
captures and b6 Lilla grabs yet another
pawn king yet and now King to e4
attacking the rook rook to f2 and now
Bishop c5 pushing the rook somewhere
else
rook the b2 and now Bishop the d4 still
harassing the rook rook to h2 and now
comes Bishop f6 putting pressure on the
night here and here problem is if you go
for something like King to be 7th to try
and get away c5 is coming c6 is coming
and your king will not have anywhere to
hide so here it's not push plate rook to
c2 going after the c4 pawn and here
comes the moment where I thought it was
incredibly funny what do you play here
like if it was your what do you play
here even pause the video
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding rook to b8
you just attack the pin piece well
basically now you're pinning the attack
piece or the other way around well it
was already a tag but now we're
attacking it twice so there's no move
here for black point is if you try and
get away for example to go for something
like this even bishop can just capture
and you're up a whole piece or even
better kink here you force the route
back and only after the rook moves so
you don't even lose the c4 pawn then you
capture this guy here and you are up a
whole piece but Lila decides against it
Lila just grabs the night and this is
what I thought it was incredibly funny
because life capablanca you used to say
you know if you complicate chests you
don't understand it and here allele also
says there's there's no need in keeping
more material on the board there the I
can just give up my bishop as well and
the position will still be just just
this winning so King captures and now
King D 3 they're pushing away the rook
not allowing to capture the c4 pawn rook
to c1
and now rook to h6 is going after the
pawn of course it's 4 points to 1 so
it's completely winning but the humor
persists with King to c7 rook captures
on h5 and kink to d6 now and now again
how would you play this position well
you'd probably try something like g4 or
your to try rocked age sex check or your
to try maybe a king to d4 and then
Rakesh would continue checking you from
behind and then you'd realize you have
no idea what you're doing
but not lela lela again just simplifies
it c5 check gives up one of the pawns
you don't need all the pawns point is if
Luke captures then b6 and now again not
much to do here if rook to b5 look the
h6 check and now if King captures you
just check and pick up the rook and then
of course this pawn is winning and if
you don't have to look to h6 check if
you go back King to b7 then came to c4
and again now whatever you do look the B
to Ruby 1 g4 is coming again the three
passed pawns are winning point is you've
pushed back the black King and now your
white king
starts marching forward so here instead
of rook captures King captures was
played but now even these six with check
lila gives yet another pawn i again if
you capture it then rook to h6 check
king at the seven rock to h7 check you
cannot go to c6 so let's say king d8 and
now king d4 and again you've pushed the
black king all the way back and your two
to pass pawns who will be completely
winning so here stockfish decided to
join in the humor he said okay I
wouldn't have to grab your pawn with
kink to d2 now rook the c8 and now the
seven and it was in this position that
stockfish resigned the game or as
engines do they decided that the
evaluation is too great to continue the
game and another great victory for Leela
this was game 38 and at the end of game
38 Leela is leading the match with a
two-point margin I don't know the exact
score but it is it is by a two-point
margin so I'm really impressive as at
some point you know the stockfish won
the game with the black pieces and then
stalkerish was leading by a point and
then Leela was able to eke whites and
now leading by two point margin really
incredible stuff here of course the the
resign is necessary because after the
roblox route d5 you will just push push
the pawns to victory for example King c4
King b3 yes you will give up this pawn
but it doesn't matter King III king c6
you're gonna go king f4 and after the
rock is captured to the King and pawn
endgame is of course winning for white
king b7 we're gonna go King g6 came here
King here and now the last point just
becomes a queen so that's another game
from the TCC super final season 17 I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Eric when right Derrick Ferraro
Geoffrey Michaels Christopher dick and
Keith tester for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video ciarán thankful for
watching and I will see you soon
continue in the coverage of the more
free saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day